merde c'est tout dégueulasse voilà ça
fera à peu près comme ça à temps une
seconde
oui vous pouvez m'appeler daniel et lui
dire de venir très vite avec un
détachement un truc puissant alors
montrez moi raconte moi voilà bon gros
et donc tu dessines tramal non mais
c'est pour vous expliquer donc la télé
envoie des ondes vers d'êtres humains et
la victime meurt à cause des ondes et or
là ce type saigne d'accord d'accord le
regarde là on comprend que la télé
rayonne grâce aux petites secondes kata
dessinée voilà c'est ça rayonne
oui mais problème c'est qu'on peut pas
le faire un film ça on peut pas filmer
des ondes ça n'existe pas comment tu vas
faire pour que les gens puissent de
trucs non mais ça c'est très simple en
fait on va entendre un ronflement un peu
comme un four micro ondes un peu moi je
vis de rajouter le sont après en fait ok